it's a weird dichotomy because when you
say restore the snyder verse you're like
well yeah i want ben affleck to be
batman in that yeah but ultimately if he
doesn't want to be then i don't think he
should if there's something happens with
discovery where they are like hey zach
let's get this going i'll be open to see
what zach can do with recasting because
of the fact that if he doesn't want to
do it then that's what's all we'd hear
is like ben affleck clearly was phoning
it
reject nation i got i got a i got a
breaking news for you i got breaking
news apparently apparently
filming the reshoots for justice league
when joss whedon took over wasn't an
enjoyable experience what i know we
might be the first to to get this to you
and o.j might have murdered his wife
it's not possible
i can't he wrote a whole book about what
he would have done we are here today to
talk about some ben affleck stuff in
regards to he reflected on his
experience during the justice league
batman time he talked about the flash
and i want to with the herald sun i
wanted to get into that as well there's
a specific thought that i wanted to
share with you guys because i am a
champion of providing restoration to the
snyder verse absolutely
however
we'll we'll go into it a little bit
basically the headline that was going
around was ben affleck says joss
whedon's justice league was the worst
experience well if you're on twitter
that's that's what it's saying right
and he did an interview with the la
times and so i was like all right i want
to read what this interview is it's not
exactly that the title of the video is
going to be that seo you know how it
goes that's right man but i do want to
say that i while i think justice league
is 100 lumped into this whole thing
there's more to it than that that
actually made me go as a person who does
want the snider verse restored i still
also feel conflicted because i i want
ben affleck to be happy and i think we
have to let him go although there's that
selfish fan in me that's like but if
zack snyder maybe wants him back he
can't say yes sir there's a lassie movie
playing in my head right now i'm just go
go there's two questions in particular
that i think provide much bigger context
than he's slamming joss whedon's justice
league the first is the prelude before
he that he's directly asked about batman
and justice league um john you want to
read the first one i would love to you
said recently that it's only in the last
few years that you felt comfortable as
an actor what shifted my whole career
i've loved acting but i kind of got to a
place where i realized i needed to
really define and stick to what my
standards were for what i wanted to do
and not be drawn into what everyone else
thinks i think it's a paradox that the
more you focus on actually trying to do
what you think is interesting and what
you want to do rather than what other
people say the better your work is and
the more relaxed you get i really like
the philosophy of what he's talking
about there of just not living by
validation and being able to do what he
personally wants to do like
self-validating himself through his
passion and career he goes on to say i
mean the last duel came out and every
article was like it made no money and i
really loved the movie and i liked what
i did in it i was disappointed more
people didn't see it but i can't chase
what's going to be cool i'm happy with
it i'm not preoccupied with notions of
success or failure about money or
commercial success i already got so much
money and i got freaking jlo man
because those things really corrupt your
choices then what happens is the movies
are less interesting and you're less
good and i think we can always pick up
on when there's a good nicholas cage
movie and a bad necklace
yeah
maybe even a good or ben bad affleck
movie so in 2016 this interviewer talked
to ben affleck three times one for
batman v superman the accountant live by
night and i got the sense you were under
a lot of pressure shortly after that you
dropped out of directing and starring in
the batman and sought treatment for your
drinking was that when your priorities
changed directing the batman is a good
example i looked at it and thought
i'm not going to be happy doing this the
person who does this should love it
you're supposed to always want these
things and i probably would have loved
doing it at 32 or something but it was
at the point where i started to realize
it's not worth it it's just a wonderful
benefit of reorienting and recalibrating
your priorities that once it started
being more about the experience i felt
more at ease and then here's where he
goes on to say the part that's being
technically quoted it was really justice
league that was the nadir for me
nadir that's a good word ben affleck the
writer in him is coming out that was a
bad experience because of a confluence
of things my own life my divorce being a
way too much the competing agendas and
then zack's personal tragedy the death
of his daughter autumn and the
re-shooting it was just the worst
experience it was awful it was
everything that i didn't like about this
that became the moment where i said i'm
not doing this anymore it's not even
about like justice league was so bad
because it could have been anything
see yeah see the clarification there of
what i'm talking about it's the
convergence of all these things that
happen to surround the filming of
justice league granted there is a
scenario that i feel like a lot of
people might be able to conjure up if
zack snyder's justice league went
smoothly and went according to plan it
just ended up being a great film-making
experience yeah maybe he wouldn't feel
this way you know but i think it's the
fact too that this can be kind of a a
whole hassle and process and there's
always a lot of reworking when it comes
to these big franchise movies and i
think that's why ben affleck has talked
recently about i'm just kind of done
with franchises because of the inner
workings that happens with a lot of them
keep in mind it's like while wb's drama
it seems to be so front and center
um every studio has its big set of
problems almost every movie has this
whole package they got to deal with you
know and he's talking about how he's
supposed to love doing this bottom line
is he he doesn't love doing this anymore
and he lost that love and passion it's
like would i really want this guy to
step into the shoes here if he no longer
feels an enthusiasm or passion for it so
i feel like we have to just let the idea
of bat flight go i don't feel like even
if he did step into it he would
ultimately be able to give the
performance or the the work that we
would even want from him and i think
that's most key it kind of makes me
think of the flash then because it seems
like that is kind of a final maybe act
of service to the fans as like a sign
off from him you know because there's
been a lot of support for him which i'm
sure he's seen and probably appreciates
so you know maybe that's you know the
reasoning for that swan song
yeah transition oh uh he was talking
with the herald sun flash on news it's a
video that where you could watch it
actually but he they pulled the quote
here that i thought was um most
significant maybe my favorite scenes in
terms of batman were in the flash i hope
they maintained the integrity of what we
did because i thought it was great and
really interesting it was
really really satisfying and encouraging
and i thought wow i think i have finally
figured it out
and then he adds that his experiences of
working on snyder cut and the flash put
a really nice finish on my experience
with that character oh he clearly feels
like he's said bye now and the way how
like andrew garfield was able to have
that kind of closure with amazing
spider-man
he can continue on if he wants whereas
ben affleck seems like he he was able to
find that piece with it as much drama as
there's been surrounding the flash and
like are they really gonna erase all
this i hope that by the time this movie
comes out ben affleck can watch it and
go that was what i was hoping for we
could do with my interpretation of
batman to say bye and that if anything
he can have a peaceful buy when it comes
to seeing his performance in the flash
yeah that's my one and only hope at this
point more so than snyder verse and all
that because i'm just that good god
but no it does it's the one thing i've
heard about the flash that perhaps get
me the most sort of spiritually excited
if that's not too silly of a thing to
say is like yeah that work and that care
and compassion for you know sending off
the character in a way that he can be
proud of like yeah i really hope that
translates there and that we all get to
feel that and that that is the kind of
guiding spirit of the movie rather than
you know like ah we gotta do a bunch of
multiverse rearranging of stuff so yes
guys i mean where does this leave us now
it's a weird dichotomy because it's like
when you when you say restore the snyder
verse you're like well yeah i want ben
affleck to be batman in that yeah but
ultimately if he doesn't want to be then
i don't think he should no so if if
something happens with discovery where
they are like hey zach let's get this
going and if they can do whatever you
want yeah you can't get ben affleck back
i i'd be open to see what zach can do
with recasting because of the fact that
if he doesn't want to do it then that's
what's what all we'd hear is like ben
affleck clearly was phoning it yeah look
at what happened to daniel craig
you gotta come back do a whole movie to
prove that you were invested
but guys what do you think about this
leave your thoughts down below
why don't you go ahead subscribe click
that bell hit that like button we will
catch you guys soon